hey everyone welcome to today's quiz on
digital marketing
let's wait for some more people to join
in
hey everyone welcome to trees quiz on
digital marketing
if you want to be an effective digital
marketer you need to know your stuff so
what's better way to check your
knowledge with a quiz we will be
proceeding with the quiz soon let's wait
for few more people to join
before we begin
and type boom in the comment section if
you are
very excited for the today's quiz
be sure to stick around till the end of
the quiz for a chance to win amazon
vouchers if you are one of the top three
winners
while we wait for others to join let's
take a quick look at what digital
marketing is and how it differs from
traditional marketing and some of the
skills needed to become a successful
digital marketer
take part in the quiz it is highly
recommended to use your mobile phone
to visit the website www.mandy.com
and use the code 99706121
the code is available on the screen as
well you can also use a different tab on
your browser to take part in the quiz
but our live stream will be broadcasting
the results as soon as the answers are
given by the participants
so it's beneficial to have both screen
visible at the same time
once you open the link and input the
code just wait for the quiz to start and
be ready to answer the questions the
quicker you answer the more points you
will get
so be sure to think fast and click
faster
so we are going to wait for a few more
minutes to let other people join before
starting our quest today meanwhile let's
understand what digital marketing is
in simple word digital marketing is the
promotion of a product or a brand
through one or more forms of electronic
media such as internet mobile phones
google search engine marketing etc
it's a way to reach clients on time and
retain them with interactive marketing
using digital technologies
also it is the most accessible easy to
use and contemporary method of promotion
which is also known as online marketing
digital now let's look into digital
marketing versus traditional marketing
several new and old businesses are
harnessing digital marketing and
rethinking their marketing funnels in
the age of digital marketing a digital
revolution has reshaped how we live
interact
and conduct businesses traditional
marketing seems to be losing its
relevance in today's era of technology
knowing which marketing method will work
best for your business is essential
traditional marketing methods such as
printing
materials radio and televisions are
quickly becoming outdated they are too
expensive ineffective and time consuming
however digital marketing is the future
of
digital marketing is the future of
advertising
let's talk about
few reasons why digital marketing is a
better choice than traditional marketing
firstly
firstly there is a global reach a
website that allows you to find new
market and trade globally for only a
small investment
the second is lower cost a properly
planned and well targeted digital
marketing campaign can reach the right
customers at a much lower cost than
traditional marketing methods
the next benefit is analytics several
tools are available to analyze and
report on marketing data collected
through digital channels and that data
is specious to any business now we are
on to our last benefit which is
retargeting suppose we have a website
that sells shoes and hundred people
visited our website but only two
purchases the item with the help of
digital marketing we can still target
those 98 visitors and display our ads to
them
now let's look at what top skills a
digital marketer needs
it is crucial for anyone planning a
career in digital marketing to
understand what are the top skills
required
it takes a wide range of soft and hard
skills for digital marketers to succeed
as a digital marketer you need a
different set of skills depending on
where you work and what you do
first is data analysis data analytics
uses functional procedures and modern
software programs to gather and analyze
information from various online
detection with your target market
the second is content creation creating
content that appeals to a brand target
audience is crucial for digital
marketing
seo and sem it is important to utilize
relevant and specific keywords as google
algorithm constantly updates
both seo and sem help you reach your
target audience and narrow down your
customer base
basic designing skills digital marketer
should be familiar with software such as
adobe creative suit photoshop after
effects illustrator and design etc
and canva as these would enhance the
ability to create visual content
social media businesses use social media
platforms to target their content to
specific audiences and get accurate data
for this reason a digital marketing
needs to be very familiar with social
media platforms and the last we have is
communication skill an influential
digital marketer should know at things
from a different perspective convey
information
is it is an easy understand manner and
figure out what audiences find
entertaining and valuable
we will start the quiz soon
let's just wait for 30 seconds
take part in the quiz it is highly
recommended to use your mobile phone to
visit the website
www.mandy.com and use the code 99706121
repeating again to take part in the quiz
it is highly recommended to use your
mobile phone to visit the website
www.mente.com
and use the code 99706121
the code is available on the screen as
well you can also use a different tab on
your browser to take part in the quiz
but our live stream will be pros
but our live stream will be broadcasting
the result as soon as the answers are
given by the participants so it's
beneficial to have both screen visible
at the same time once you open the link
and input the code just wait for the
quiz to start and be ready to answer the
questions the quicker you answer the
more point you get so be sure to think
fast and click faster
you want more participants to join in if
you haven't joined yet please make sure
you visit www.mandy.com
and use the code 99706121
the code is also available on the screen
we want more people to join in
if you haven't joined the quiz yet you
can go to mandy.com and use the code
which is available on the screen
so let's start with the question number
one
what's the biggest challenge for most
businesses when going online
and here are the options planning a
budget developing a plan optimizing a
website
and defining a customer base
please make sure to answer quickly if
you answer quick then you will get more
points
what's the biggest challenge for most
businesses when going online
planning a budget developing a plan
optimizing a website or defining a
customer base
so the time is up
10 people
has corrected the answer
the correct answer is to develop a plan
most of you think optimizing a budget is
the biggest challenge but it's tough to
move forward without a proper plan as an
organization goes online the most
significant barrier for them is
developing a plan to progress their
business the main problem is that some
small business owners feels that they
can acquire clients quickly but until
that occurs initiatives are developed it
is crucial to determine your
target audience and your organization
priorities as you create a strategy
so let's have a look on the leaderboard
data nerd is at the number one position
punya at the second position and akshay
is at the third position
so let's get started with the question
number two
so first to get more points
what are the four piece of marketing
here are the options price popularity
people placement and the second option
is popularity product promotion and
people and the third option is people
price promotion
and placement and the last option is
product price place and promotion
what are the fourth piece of marketing
very few
so the time is up
only few people are able to answer it
answer this question correctly
have a look at the leaderboard
so data nerd has shifted from first
position to the third position and punya
as at the first position
now let's start the third question
when you link google ads with google
analytics you are able to understand
which are driving performance and the
options are organic keywords social
media ads paid keywords and directories
i repeat i'm repeating the question
again when you link google ads with
google analytics you are able to
understand which are driving the
performance and the options are organic
keywords social media ads paid keywords
and directories
very few seconds are left
what's up
only 11 people are able to answer it
correctly
the correct answer is c paid keywords in
google ads you bid on paid keywords as a
result when you click when you link
google ads to google analytics you can
see which paid keywords are driving
performance
let's have a look at the leaderboard
data nerd is picking up
he get back to the first position again
now let's get started with the question
number four
please make sure you answer fast to get
more points
the question number four is which of the
following factors can impact the open
rate of your email campaign and the
options are the amount of link contained
in the email the second option is the
number of images in your email
the third option is the opportunity for
customers to opt out and the fourth
option is the subject line of the email
which of the following factors can
impact the open rate of your email
campaign
very few seconds are left
14 people have answered it correctly the
subject line of the email
correct answer is d but have you thought
about why we choose option 4 insist of
instead of any other options according
to several recent market research the
subject line of an email makes a
difference whether it is opened or
repaired or replied to for example if a
number appears in the subject line the
response rate and open rate increases
additionally the subject line reinforces
the recipient's sense of trust and
generate interest your subject line must
be so compelling that it makes the
readers want to read your email and take
actions
an email campaign aims to build trust
which you can
through influential subject lines due to
this the subject line of an email is
most crucial factor that impacts the
open rate
let's have a look at the leaderboard
most of you have answered this question
correctly
so at the first position we have punya
at the second position we have data nerd
and the third position we have akshay
so let's get started to the question
number five
and so fast to get more points
what is the term we use to describe how
search engine categorize each piece of
content and here are the options listing
crawling indexing and ranking
i am repeating the question again what
is the term we use to describe how
search engines categorize each piece of
content
and the option are
listing
crawling indexing and ranking
very few seconds are left
so make sure
you answer this question correctly
so 14 people have answered this question
correctly
so now let's have a look at the
leaderboard razor shuffle there is a
little bit shuffle in the leaderboard
punya is still at the number one
position
moving on let's get
moving on let's get started with the
question number six
considering expanding a business
internationally the best place to start
is
use online tools to help you understand
where there's strong demand the second
option is move the whole business to
that country
and the third option is replicating your
current business
in as many countries as possible
and the last option is
buy new
buy new domains for the country
very few seconds are left
the best place to start when considering
an international expansion is by using
online tools to understand where there
is a strong demand for your products
with the help of marketplace data you
can identify markets where your product
is in the high demand and determine the
competitiveness of those markets in
additional you can learn about the
challenges and opportunities in your
target market by conducting surveys and
interviews with local entrepreneurs
let's have a look at the leaderboard
is still at the number one position
akshay is at the second position and
harshat is at the third position
moving forward let's have a look at
question number seven
and so first to get more points
what methods of social
network marketing should a company
always use
options are blogs
twitter blogs facebook third option is
youtube and the fourth option is depends
on the company their products and their
audience
i'm repeating the options again the
first option is blogs second option is
twitter blogs and facebook
third option is youtube and the fourth
option is depending on the company their
product and their audience
18 people have answered this question
correctly
now let's have a look at the leaderboard
oniya is still at the number one
position
data node
is at the second position and her shut
at the third position
moving forward let's have a look at
question number seven
sorry my bad it's question number eight
which of the following is the correct
name for social for facebook ranking
algorithm
and the option are face rank edge rank
like rank
and page rank
which of the following is the correct
name for facebook ranking algorithm
and the options are face rank edge rank
like rank and pagerank
only 8 seconds are left
please make sure you answer this
question correctly
to get at the top of the leaderboard
the time is up
only 10 people have answered this
question correctly the correct answer is
edge
rank rank algorithm determines where and
what your posts appear in each
individual news feed
now let's have a look at the leaderboard
is shifted to the fourth position and no
master has
taken the punya's position
is still at this second position and
harshat
at the third position
let's get started with the question
number nine
answer first to get more points
which of the following is the correct
abbreviation of cms
it's a very easy cost it's a very easy
question
the options are contentment content
maintenance site content maintenance
system content management system and the
fourth option is content marketing
system
hope most of you will answer this
question correctly
which of the following is the correct
abbreviation of cms
answer is c
the a content management system is an
application that allows a user to
organize publish edit delete and modify
the content in a centralized interface
the cms can easily be handled by both
iit and non id personal
since it does not require specialized
knowledge
let's have a look at the leaderboard
master is still at the first position
quick forward let's get started with the
question number 10
each of the following metric is used for
tracking the status of email marketing
and the options are conversion rate open
rate bounce rate all of the above
repeating the question again which of
the following metric is used for
tracking the status of email marketing
and the options are conversion rate open
rate bounce rate and all of the above
very few seconds are left
please make sure you answer this
question correctly to get at the top of
the leaderboard
so the time is up
18 people are able to answer this
question correctly
sir sd all of the above all three
conversion rate open date and bounce
rate is used for tracking the status of
email marketing the conversion rate is
used to track the number of conversions
the open rate is about how many people
opened your email and the bounce rate is
how many emails were not delivered to
the respective email address
now let's have a look at the leaderboard
there is lot of shuffling in the
leaderboard data nut is at the first
position new master is at the second
position and harshat is at the third
position
here is the quick reminder here is the
quick reminder send your screenshot
after the quiz
to the email id youtube there it
simplylearn.com to receive your amazon
vouchers
this is for the top three winners
let's have a look at the question number
11.
answer first to get more points
retargeting allows you to
and here are the options
target users based on the specific
action they take on your site target
people based on their likes and interest
appear higher with the search results
and the last option is target people
before they come to your website
this question is about retargeting
very few seconds are left
so please make sure you
answer quickly
so the time is up
13 people are able to answer this
question correctly
the answer is a target users based on
the specific actions they take on your
site retargeting is targeting a user who
has already visited your website and
taken a particular action for example if
the user visited your e-commerce website
and added the product to your cart and
then left the side without making a
purchase
this user can be retargeted with the ads
related to your products
now let's have a look at the leaderboard
now there is a shift in the first
position david james is now at the first
position
anna is at the second position so there
is a change in the second position as
well
forward let's get started with the
question number 12
social network is considered the most
popular for business to business
marketing
or a or a b2b marketing
the options are facebook twitter
instagram london
repeating the question again which
social network is considered the most
popular for business to business
marketing or b2b marketing the options
are facebook twitter instagram and
linkedin
very few seconds are left
13 people answer this question correctly
the correct answer is linkedin as a
popular social media network and a
platform for b2b marketing linkedin is
growing rapidly
it effectively builds a solid
professional network every business
seeks and has already become an integral
part of digital marketing
let's have a look at the leaderboard
there is again a change at the first
position arnov is now at the first
position
he answered the question
let's get started with the question
number 13.
which of the which of these two
strategies can help your social media
content go viral
the first option is news checking of
breaking news items second option is
strongly emotional content
third option is both a and b
and the final option is only a
i'm repeating the options again
news checking of breaking news items
second option is strongly emotional
content
third option is both a and b
and the fourth and the last option is
only a
m is
up so 15 people are able to answer this
question correctly
people want to go viral on social media
and they are looking for ways to do so
since some people use trending news and
some use emotional content both of these
strategies worked well for most
businesses and individual users
people watch news content to stay up to
date while emotional content enables
brands to connect with their audience
better
both are correct emotional content and
trending news content
now let's have a look at the leaderboard
is a shuffle in the leaderboard on the
first position david is now at the first
position
now let's get started with the question
number 14.
the first to get more points
question number 14 is when search engine
use factors like geolocation ip address
and location based on search terms to
produce geographical
tailored
the options are local search
jio search
mobile search organic search
i'm repeating the options again
local search is the first option second
option is jio search third option is
mobile search and the fourth option is
organic search
so
while people are able to answer this
question correctly
the correct answer is local search
is a subset of search tool that filters
and source based on the user's job
location on the web and displays the
user and things
and around the jio location both
digitally and geographic
jio search also helps companies and
other commercial providers to showcase
things or items that the user can find
around him and herself based on the
location filter
master is picking up now new master is
at the second position and david is
still at the
first rank
now let's have a look on question number
15.
it's the first to get more points
which of the following will be achieved
by including an offer in a search engine
marketing or sem ad
and the option are it will help the ad
stand out and encourage people to click
it the second option is it will gen
it will guarantee the ad appears at the
top of the search result and the third
option is it will increase the amount of
users
across your entire website
and the final option is it can increase
the quality score of your ad
getting the question again which of the
following will be achieved by including
an offer in a search engine marketing or
a sem ad
very few seconds are left so make sure
you answer this question quickly
miss op
12 people are able to answer this
question correctly
the correct answer is a it will help the
ad stand out and encourage people to
click it it will help boost traffic to
the website and generate more leads
offers usually attract people and
because of the discount most people
don't want to miss out and they will
click your advertisement to find out
more
let's have a look at the leaderboard
david is still at the first position new
master
is at the second rank and her [ __ ] is at
the third rank
moving forward let's have a look at
question number 16.
here do we use keywords
the options are tags title description
and all of the above
it's a very simple question
where do we use keywords and the options
are tags title description and the
fourth option is all of the above
i hope most of the people have already
answered this question correctly as it
is the very easy question
amazon
15 people are able
to answer this question correctly
answer is d all of the above using
keywords on the title tags and
description increases the chances of
ranking at the top of the search engine
hence we use keywords in all these three
places
on the leaderboard davis's david is at
the first position and hershat
is at the second and the third is data
node
now let's have a look at question number
17.
if you answer this question quickly you
will get more points
this is of length of blanks question
dash falls under the eb testing tools
and the options are google content
experiments visible websites visual
website optimizer and the third option
is both a and b
and the last option is none of the above
only few seconds are left so make sure
you answer this question correctly
time is up
14 people are able to answer this
question correctly
correct answer is c
visual website optimizer google content
optimizer and optimizely are most
commonly used a b testing tool it is an
easy to use a b testing tool that allows
marketers to create a variety of
different landing pages and web pages
using a simple point and click editor no
coding skills are required and then test
which
version yields the greatest conversions
the google optimize tool is an online
spread testing tool that allows you to
experiment with the way your content is
delivered on your website it facilitates
three types of testing a b testing
multi-variety and redirect tests
now let's have a look at the leaderboard
post position is changed now hershey is
at the number one position
and data not is at the second and david
shifted to the third position
moving forward let's have a look at
question number 18.
number 18 is if you are looking to
attract people to your social network
what tone of voice should you consider
and here are the options the first
option is stern and serious the second
option is serient serious and honest
and the third option is fun and inviting
and the last option is engaging and
inviting
i'm repeating the options again stern
and serious serious and honest
fun and inviting and the last option is
engaging and inviting
amazon
20 people are able to answer this
question correctly
the answer is d engaging and inviting a
tone of voice that is engaging and
inviting will help you attract people to
your social network make your stories as
engaging as possible and write as if you
are a friend or a christian of theirs
keep your post concise and engaging this
will make your social media post and ads
more engaging
now let's have a look at the leaderboard
[ __ ] bajaj is at the first position
david is at the second position and the
third position
as data node
now let's have a look at question number
19
which of the following formulas is used
by pay-per-click
this is an interesting question
which of the following formulas is used
by pay-per-click
the option
adds click divided by advertising cost
advertising cost plus ads click
the third option is advertise
zinc cost divided by ads collect and the
last option is ads clicked
multiply advertising cost
ms up
11 people are able to answer this
question correctly
the correct answer is c
ppc allows you to purchase visits to
your website rather than attempting to
earn visits organically
and the advice and the advertising cost
divided by ads clicked
formula is used by ppc
now let's have a look at the leaderboard
there is a
shuffle at the second and third position
now data nerd is at the second position
and david has shifted to the third
position
now let's get started with the question
number 20.
number 20 is google analytics cannot
recognize returning users on mobile apps
this statement is true
false can be true or false
and the fourth option is not defined
i am ripping the question again google
analytics cannot recognize returning
users on mobile apps
and the options are true
second option is false and the third
option is can be true or false and the
fourth option is not defined
answer
is p false
this statement is false has the correct
answer is b
using the google analytics tool you can
analyze the behavior of your website
visitors and you can identify returning
visitors on mobile apps on google
analytics
now let's have a look at the leaderboard
there is a shuffling
on the top three position harshad
is now
at the first position data nerd is at
the second position and the third
position
taken by akshat
akshay
now let's have a look at question number
21.
only five questions are left
what is the best practice to draw the
attention of people in an online world
where attention span is very short
and the options are
writing engaging online copy the second
option is keeping the target audience in
mind the third option is understanding
the user journey
and the last option is being consistent
in your approach to copy
this is also interesting question i hope
most of the people were able to answer
this correctly
time is up
only few people are able to answer this
question correctly writing engaging
online copy is the correct answer
content is the
cornerstone of all good marketing
without it you have no brand without it
you have no conversion without it you
have no sales
good writing can do more than just
entertain it can also change people's
mind so a great hook is essential to
draw people in
now let's have a look at the leaderboard
as many people answer this question
wrong
we will see a shuffle
in the leaderboard so now data nerd is
at the first position hershey is at the
second
and davis is at the third position
now let's have a look at question number
22.
which of these are a type of ad
photo ads video ads corrosion ads story
ads slideshow ads
the options are all except five
second option is first second and fourth
the third option is first and second
the last option is all five
this is a little bit tricky question
let's see
who are able to answer this question
correctly
time is up
so 14 people are able to answer this
question correctly the correct answer is
d all five the first four may be
the first four maybe you are familiar
with and you might get confused with the
slideshow ad the facebook slideshow ad
is a video like ad that uses motion
sound and text to tell story across all
devices
it loads quickly so it works
well on any internet connection
now let's have a look at the leaderboard
[ __ ] is shifted to the first position
data note is at the second and now is
taken the third position
let's have a look at question number 23
how many ad extensions should you
include in your search ad
and the options are three
second option is five
third option is all that are available
the final option is as many as makes
sense for your business
repeating the question again
how many ad extensions should you
include in your search ad
very few seconds are left
15 people are able to answer this
question correctly the correct answer is
d as many as makes sense for your
business there is no right number
regarding the number of ad extensions
you should include your in your search
ads
it is essential to consider a few
factors
including your target audience your
budget and the design of your ads
ultimately you need to decide what work
best for your business
now let's have a look at the leaderboard
rashid is still at the first position
nerd is at the second position and the
third position is on
only two questions are left
hence let's
have a look at the 24th question
question
24th question is which of the following
is a core benefit that content marketing
can bring to a business online presence
it can improve
actions by directing more traffic to
your website
it can enable a business to create a
bank of content which can be reused to
create ads and the third option is it
helps a company identify its
biggest competitors
and the last option is it provides you
with another channel to push sites and
messages to customer as a on a regular
basis
so
19 people are able to answer this
question correctly the correct answer is
a
it can approve sales by directing more
traffic to your website
content marketing aims to increase brand
awareness by telling stories and sharing
information ultimately the goal is to
encourage readers to become customers by
signing up for an email list asking for
more information or making a purchase
and all of these steps improve sales
now let's have a look at the leaderboard
hershey is still at the first position
data nerd is at the second position and
a nub is at the third position
now we have uh the final question
question number 25
looking to get noticed locally online
what information should you ensure is on
your website as a minimum
option number first is your social media
links second option is an interactive
map
the third option is your physical
location details
and the last option is business
registration number
only 10 seconds are left
so make sure you answer this question
quickly
so
only 12 people are able to answer this
question correctly your physical
location detail the correct answer is c
you may find it challenging to stand out
from the crowd
when seeking local attention online
however by ensuring your website
contains your physical location details
you can increase the chances of being
found by potential customers this
information can be included in your
about us section or or in a dedicated
location on your website by having this
information you will be able to more
likely to attract the attention of
potential clients and partners
let's have a look at the leaderboard
this is the final leaderboard
let's see
once the quiz
data not
is the winner
of today's digital marketing quiz
please make sure you
click that you take the screenshot and
send
the screenshot to youtube
simplylearn.net
thank you for joining
thank you everyone for joining us
and
you just need to send your screenshot to
youtube
simplylearn.net to receive your amazon
voucher
it is a very important step
so for all the top three winners please
make sure you take the screenshot and
send it to youtube
simplylearn.net to receive your amazon
vouchers
you